vous faites concurrence sur le plan de la qualité de vos produits,
des prix que vous pouvez offrir,
des services et des innovations que vous créez.
C'est cela, la compétition sur les mérites.
Dans un tel marché, vous avez des chances égales de réussir.
Et c'est mon travail,
en tant que commissaire à la concurrence,
de faire en sorte que les entreprises qui font des affaires en Europe
suivent ces règles.
Mais, prenons du recul.
Pourquoi avons-nous besoin de règles en matière de concurrence ?
Pourquoi ne pas laisser simplement les entreprises se concurrencer ?
N'est-ce pas aussi ce qu'il y a de mieux pour nous,
qu'ils se concurrencent librement,
vu que plus de concurrence entraîne plus de qualité,
des prix plus bas, plus d'innovation ?
Eh bien, généralement, c'est le cas.
Mais le problème est que, parfois, pour les entreprises,
la concurrence peut être...
gênante.
Parce que la concurrence implique que la course n'est jamais finie,
que le jeu n'est jamais gagné.
Quel que soit votre degré de réussite dans le passé,
il y a toujours quelqu'un, là, désireux de prendre votre place.
Donc, la tentation d'éviter la concurrence est très grande.
Elle a ses racines dans des raisons aussi vieilles qu'Adam et Ève :
l'avidité pour toujours plus d'argent,
la peur de perdre notre position sur le marché
et tous les bénéfices qu'elle apporte.
Quand cupidité et peur sont associées au pouvoir,
vous obtenez une combinaison dangereuse.
Nous observons cela dans la vie politique.
Dans certaines parties du monde,
le mélange de cupidité et de peur signifie que ceux qui ont obtenu du pouvoir
sont alors peu disposés à le rendre.
Une des nombreuses choses que j'aime et admire dans nos démocraties,
ce sont les normes qui conduisent nos dirigeants à céder le pouvoir
quand les électeurs le leur demandent.
En fait, les règles de concurrence peuvent faire la même chose sur le marché,
veiller à ce que cupidité et peur n'outrepassent pas les règles d'équité.
Car ces règles veulent dire que les entreprises
ne peuvent pas abuser de leur pouvoir pour éliminer la concurrence.
Pensez un instant à votre voiture.
Elle a des milliers de pièces,
de la mousse qui constitue les sièges
au câblage électrique, aux lampes...
Et pour nombre de ces pièces, les constructeurs automobiles mondiaux
dépendent d'un petit nombre seulement de fournisseurs.
Il n'y a donc rien d'étonnant
à ce que ces fournisseurs soient quelque peu tentés de s'unir
et fixer les prix.
Mais imaginez les conséquences
sur le prix final de votre nouvelle voiture sur le marché.
Sauf que, ce n'est pas imaginaire.
La Commission Européenne
a déjà affaire à sept cartels de pièces automobiles différents,
et nous sommes encore en train d'enquêter sur certains.
Ici, le Département de la Justice
est aussi en train de faire l'examen du marché des pièces automobiles,
et il l'a appelé « la plus grande enquête criminelle qu'il ait jamais poursuivie. »
Mais sans règles de concurrence,
il n'y aurait aucune enquête,
et rien n'arrêterait la formation de cette collusion,
ni l'augmentation du prix de votre voiture.
Mais, les entreprises ne sont pas seules à pourvoir saper la concurrence loyale.
Les gouvernements le peuvent aussi.
Et les gouvernements le font quand ils distribuent des subventions
au petit nombre de favoris,
les sélectionnés.
Ils peuvent le faire en donnant des subventions -
le tout financé, bien sûr, par les contribuables -
aux entreprises,
sous la forme, par exemple, de traitements fiscaux spéciaux,
comme les avantages fiscaux
alloués à des firmes telles que Fiat, Starbucks et Apple
par certains gouvernements en Europe.
Ces subventions empêchent les entreprises de se concurrencer sur un pied d'égalité.
Elles peuvent impliquer que les compagnies qui réussissent
sont les compagnies obtenant le plus de subventions,
celles qui ont le plus de contacts,
et non, comme il se devrait,
les entreprises servant le mieux les consommateurs.
Donc, il y a des moments où nous devons intervenir
pour veiller à ce que la concurrence fonctionne comme elle le devrait.
Ce faisant, nous aidons le marché à fonctionner de manière équitable,
parce que la concurrence donne aux clients le pouvoir d'exiger une transaction juste.
Cela signifie que les entreprises savent que si elles ne peuvent pas offrir
de bons prix ou le service demandé,
eh bien...
les clients iront ailleurs.
Ce genre d'équité est plus important qu'on ne le croit parfois.
Peu de gens pensent sans arrêt à la politique.
Certains mêmes l'ignorent au moment des élections.
Mais nous sommes tous dans le marché.
Nous sommes dans le marché tous les jours.
Nous ne voulons pas que les entreprises s'entendent
sur les prix, dans le back office.
Nous ne voulons pas qu'ils se partagent le marché.
Nous ne voulons pas d'une seule grande compagnie excluant ses concurrents
pour les empêcher de nous montrer ce qu'ils peuvent faire.
Quand cela arrive,
alors bien sûr, nous avons l'impression que quelqu'un nous a trompés,
que nous avons été ignorés ou tenus pour acquis par le marché.
Cela peut compromettre non seulement notre confiance dans le marché
mais aussi notre confiance dans la société.
Dans une étude récente,
plus des deux tiers des Européens
disent qu'ils ont ressenti les effets du manque de compétition,
que le prix de l'électricité était trop haut,
que le prix des médicaments dont ils ont besoin était trop haut,
qu'ils n'avaient pas de vrai choix s'ils voulaient voyager en bus ou en avion,
ou qu'ils recevaient un service médiocre de la part de leur fournisseur internet.
Bref, ils trouvaient que le marché ne les traitait pas équitablement.
Certes, ces choses peuvent paraître très insignifiantes,
mais elles peuvent vous donner l'impression
que le monde n'est pas vraiment juste.
Et ils voient le marché, qui était supposé servir tout le monde,
devenir plutôt la propriété privée de quelques entreprises puissantes.
Le marché n'est pas la société.
Nos sociétés sont, bien sûr, bien plus que le marché.
Mais le manque de confiance dans le marché
peut se répercuter sur la société,
de telle sorte que nous perdons aussi confiance dans la société.
Et la confiance, c'est peut-être la chose la plus importante que nous ayons.
Nous pouvons nous faire mutuellement confiance si nous sommes traités en égaux,
si nous avons tous les mêmes chances.
Nous avons tous à suivre les mêmes règles fondamentales.
Bien sûr, certaines personnes et quelques entreprises
réussissent plus que d'autres,
mais nous ne faisons pas confiance à une société
si les prix sont remis avant même que la compétition ne commence.
C'est là que les règles de concurrence entrent en jeu.
Car, quand vous veillez à ce que les marchés fonctionnent équitablement,
les entreprises se concurrencent sur la base des mérites,
ce qui contribue à créer la confiance dont nous avons besoin en tant que citoyens,
pour nous sentir à l'aise et aux commandes,
ainsi que la confiance qui permet à notre société de fonctionner.
Parce que sans confiance, tout devient plus difficile.
Dans notre vie quotidienne, nous avons besoin de faire confiance à des étrangers:
faire confiance aux banques qui gardent notre argent,
aux constructeurs qui bâtissent nos maisons,
l’électricien qui vient réparer l'installation,
le médecin qui nous soigne en cas de maladie,
sans parler des autres conducteurs sur la route
et tout le monde sait qu'ils sont fous.
Et pourtant, nous devons compter sur eux pour faire le nécessaire.
Et le fait est que plus nos sociétés grandissent,
plus la confiance devient importante
et plus il est difficile de l'installer.
Et ceci est un paradoxe des sociétés modernes.
C'est particulièrement vrai
quand la technologie change la façon dont nous interagissons.
La technologie nous aide, dans une certaine mesure,
à instaurer la confiance entre nous par des systèmes de notation et autres,
qui permettent l'économie du partage.
Mais la technologie crée aussi des défis complètement nouveaux
quand elle nous demande de ne pas faire confiance aux autres,
mais de faire confiance aux algorithmes et aux ordinateurs.
Bien sûr, nous voyons tous, partageons et apprécions
tout le bien que les technologies nouvelles nous apportent.
Il y a beaucoup de bon.
La voiture autonome offre une nouvelle indépendance aux personnes handicapées.
Elle nous sauve la vie constamment et utilise beaucoup mieux les ressources.
Les algorithmes s'appuyant sur l'analyse d'une énorme quantité de données
peuvent permettre aux médecins de nous donner un meilleur traitement,
et bien d'autres choses encore.
Mais personne ne va transmettre ses informations médicales
ni monter dans une voiture conduite par un algorithme,
sans faire confiance aux entreprises avec lesquelles elle traite.
Et cette confiance n'est pas toujours là.
Aujourd'hui, par exemple, moins d'un quart des Européens
font confiance aux entreprises en ligne
pour protéger leurs informations personnelles.
Mais, que se passerait-il si les gens savaient
qu'ils peuvent compter sur les sociétés de technologie
pour les traiter équitablement ?
Que se passerait-il s'ils savaient que ces compagnies
répondent à la concurrence en essayant de faire mieux,
en essayant de mieux servir les consommateurs,
et non en utilisant leur pouvoir pour évincer les concurrents
en repoussant, par exemple, leur services
très loin derrière, dans la liste des résultats de recherche,
et en se mettant eux-mêmes en avant ?
Que se passerait-il s'ils savaient que le respect des règles
a été intégré aux algorithmes dès la conception,
que les algorithmes doivent apprendre les règles de concurrence
avant d'être autorisés à travailler,
que ces algorithmes ont été conçus
d'une telle manière qu'ils ne peuvent pas être complices,
ils ne peuvent pas former leur propre petit cartel
dans la boîte noire dans laquelle ils travaillent ?
Conjointement avec la législation,
les règles de la concurrence peuvent faire cela.
Elles peuvent nous aider à veiller
à ce que les technologies nouvelles traitent les gens équitablement
et que tout le monde se concurrence à égalité de chances.
Et ceci peut nous aider
à instaurer la confiance nécessaire
à l'épanouissement d'une réelle innovation,
et au développement de sociétés bénéfiques aux citoyens.
Parce que la confiance ne peut pas être imposée,
elle doit être gagnée.
Dès les premiers jours de la Communauté Européenne,
il y a 60 ans,
nos règles de concurrence ont contribué à instaurer cette confiance.
Beaucoup de choses ont changé.
Il est difficile de dire ce que ces six représentants
auraient fait d'un smartphone.
Mais dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
tout comme dans le leur,
la concurrence fait que le marché fonctionne pour tout le monde.
C'est pourquoi, je suis convaincue
qu'une concurrence vraie et juste
a un rôle vital à jouer
dans l'instauration de la confiance dont nous avons besoin,
pour tirer le meilleur parti de nos sociétés.
Et cela commence par faire appliquer les règles,
juste pour faire en sorte que le marché fonctionne pour tout le monde.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Bruno Giussani : Merci.
Merci.
Margrethe Vestager : Avec plaisir.
B.G. : J'ai deux questions à vous poser.
La première porte sur les données : il me semble
que la technologie et les données changent la façon dont s'opère la concurrence
et la façon dont les règles de concurrence sont conçues et appliquées.
Pouvez-vous commenter ce point ?
M. V. : Oui, c'est vraiment un défi pour nous,
car nous devons à la fois perfectionner nos outils
et en créer, également, de nouveaux.
En parcourant les réponses de Google
à notre déclaration d'opposition,
nous avons examiné 5,2 téraoctets de données.
C'est beaucoup.
Donc, nous avons dû installer de nouveaux systèmes.
Nous avons dû comprendre comment le faire,
car vous ne pouvez pas travailler comme vous le faisiez quelques années plus tôt.
Donc certainement, nous affinons nos méthodes de travail.
De plus, nous essayons de différencier les différents types de données,
car certaines sont extrêmement précieuses
et formeront une sorte de barrière pour l'entrée dans le marché.
D'autres, vous pouvez les [écarter], elles perdent leur valeur le lendemain.
Donc, nous essayons de veiller à ne jamais sous-estimer
le fait que les données fonctionnent, dans le marché, comme une devise
et comme un atout qui peut représenter un obstacle réel à la concurrence.
B. G.: Google. Vous leur avez infligés une amende de 2,8 milliards d'euros récemment.
M. V. : Non, dollars. Il n'est pas fort ces temps-ci.
B. G. : Ah, oui, cela dépend...
(Rires)
B. G. : Google a fait appel. La Cour a été saisie.
Cela va prendre du temps.
L'année dernière, vous aviez réclamé à Apple 13 milliards d'impôts rétroactifs,
et vous avez aussi enquêté sur les autres entreprises
y compris les compagnies européennes et russes, pas seulement américaines.
Pourtant, les enquêtes concernant les compagnies américaines
sont celles qui ont suscité le plus d'intérêt
et elles ont provoqué aussi quelques accusations.
Vous avez été accusée, en gros, de protectionnisme, de jalousie,
ou d'utiliser la loi pour attaquer les compagnies américaines
qui ont conquis les marchés européens.
Juste cette semaine, [la revue] The Economist a écrit à la une :
« Vestager versus Silicon Valley »
Quelle est votre réaction ?
M. V. : Premièrement, je le prends très sérieusement,
parce que la partialité n'a pas sa place dans le respect des lois.
Nous devons démontrer nos cas
avec les preuves, les faits, la jurisprudence,
dans le but, aussi, de les présenter aux tribunaux.
Deuxièmement, l'Europe est ouverte au commerce
mais pas à la fraude fiscale.
(Applaudissements)
Le fait est que nous sommes en train de changer.
Par exemple, quand je demande à mes filles -
qui utilisent aussi Google - « Pourquoi le faites-vous ? »
Elle disent : « Parce ça marche. C'est un très bon produit. »
Jamais, au grand jamais, elles ne me répondront :
« Parce que c'est un produit américain. »
C'est juste parce que ça marche.
Et c'est, bien sûr, comme cela devrait être.
Mais il est quand même important que quelqu'un se charge de dire :
« Bon, nous vous félicitons
alors que vous continuez à grandir, grandir, et grandir,
mais les félicitations s'arrêtent
quand nous découvrons que vous abusez de votre position
au détriment des concurrents,
afin qu'ils ne puissent pas servir les consommateurs. »
B. G. : Un cas fascinant à suivre.
Merci de votre venue à TED.
M. V. : Ce fut un plaisir. Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)